boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake I'm
very excited to be still at Coe Fez the
Congress on the future of engineering
software for our second annual
partnership with them we are now with
John last week hello oh thank you for
having me thanks for coming on to the
show really appreciate it wonderful
being here very excited to talk about
you talk about up chain John's
backgrounds crazy 25 years of
engineering date of Management two and a
half years now is the CEO and founder of
up chain which is doing cloud PLM
product lifecycle management
integrating product data up and down the
value chain driving collaboration
innovation and growth so now let's talk
about your journey getting into
engineering software how did it even
piqued your interest and you get
involved well I graduate with a dual
degree one in mechanical engineering and
one in computer science and my first
jobs were doing engineering work at a
couple companies and through that and
linking the the computer science part of
it I end up doing automation and helping
the companies be more productive in
their work from that I end up running
multinationals and nearing data
requirements and integrating them
globally as they were they're scaling up
and growing through acquisitions that
led to me being hired by Siemens and
running their consulting services
practice for North American aerospace
and got into the into the field that way
not really a conscious decision but it
just as typically things happen and I
think in life one small decision led to
another and and Here I am yeah so so
tell us about like the initial times
when you're seeing this globally become
a big deal with data and manufacturing
processes and design and engineering how
did how did you first see this evolving
and you getting more and more involved
with with making processes more
effective well it's really started with
the the capabilities on the engineering
side and the abilities to do engineering
on a global front to the necessity of it
as as the supply chain has proliferated
around the world and opening up
economies so it first started with
manufacturing and manufacturing being
distributed around the world and and the
requirement for if you're manufacturing
you need the product details of what am
I making
right and
that led into the next step where the
the supply chain became a lot more
effective and started doing its
capabilities grew so now you have
companies out there that smaller
companies but they they have some very
good expertise in products that they
bring to market that are absorbed by
others and you've got this whole value
network of companies that need to work
together to bring a product to market
like a prime example is Apple
where would Apple be without its supply
chain right not only in terms of
manufacturing which is a core key but if
you look at it Apple does a lot of
systems integrations they find key new
technologies and they absorb it into
their product by collaborating and
partnering with the people that actually
invented this up the the products yes so
a big part of the awakening to the
importance of the engineering and design
process was the globalised movement
correct so globalization and supply
chain and engineers and developers and
designers from around the world have to
now collaborate in a very seamless
product like radical management and all
that's been enabled not just because the
products are getting more complicated
but there's there's a revolution going
on in the world in terms of the
complexity the ability to manufacture
the scale of things that are going on
right so the in certain regions you
can't do something else and other
regions are much better for it
originally manufacturing in China for
instance that they could scale very
quickly and be bring people on board all
of this was enabled by technology right
and and the computer systems being able
to manage that data and allow for data
to be to be shared ok then how did the
idea of up chain come to be was it the
you seeing all of what you're describing
now and saying I want to build the best
solution to this so the idea really is
is a slots like twist to what's going on
typically in terms of PLM software so
we're we are meant to be an agile PLM
infrastructure for collaborating across
the board in an agile fashion so what
what I someone is out there there's the
democratization of the data and ability
to work in it was being held back by the
technology the current PLM systems that
are out there are very good and have
been designed and used by large
corporations who can go
their implement very expensive software
customized the hell out of it to fit
their business processes and then also
go in there and homogenize the data the
supply chain downstream does not have
those resources number one and number
two does not have the ability to
standardize and and direct what cought
systems they use what metadata what
workflows that's all being driven by the
their customers at the top right so they
need to be able to manage data work
close people in in a very agile fashion
through heterogeneous data right and so
there is isn't a solution out there that
can handle the heterogeneous data Multi
cad multi workflows be able to put a
bill of material together with subsets
being being developed by developed and
manufactured by different companies that
don't have the same standards that niche
on heterogeneous data being able to
manage it a jolly collaboratory in real
time and be on board and off more people
as you need it is what up chain is all
about so we do not go in and we do not
sell for instance to the OEMs as their
prime system of record for for PLM data
we're complementary to it so if you've
got a General Motors and we've got
customers like this that are down the
supply chain we are the linker or the
Babel Fish of engineering get it to B go
up and down the supply chain and when we
go all the way up they typically have a
very ingrained PLM systems that were
complimentary to and we integrate to
them
yep downstream where they cannot afford
those monolithic enterprise systems
that's our niche to be the system a
record for them down downstream upstream
the system of record are the the big PLM
systems okay okay so the the words I
think that really important here you're
on the agile and then you're also
heterogeneous data so to be able to
communicate across all parts of the of
the PLM across from the upstream to the
downstream and the upstream meaning the
the the companies that actually sell to
to customer side yeah and then the
downstream meaning the designers and
engineers so so up saw upstream meaning
the companies that actually take the
product to market apple for instance yes
is at the top of the food chain
okay at the bottom of the food chain are
small companies that might be working on
I don't know the keyboard for it oh
right so that's the supply yes
okay so Oh Apple outsource is the
keyboard to be done by third party X
okay the keyboard company needs the
little plastic springs and they found a
company that's really good at they also
outsource to somebody else and it's
trickle-down effect through that value
network of a break of the products
involved in creating the CIM the
commercial product has a whole bunch of
products sub products and subsystems in
it that need to be collaborated on and
integrated to yes and then how and then
the up chain would then enable the ones
that are putting together the keyboard
at the very low in the lowest parts of
the chain to to have the data
heterogeneous ly be able to flow where
everyone kind of understands it all the
way up to selling it to the customer
correct okay okay now what what is what
is the the heterogeneity of the data how
do you do that process so we've built an
application with some with some
technologies in it that is allows you to
easily translate data and and flip over
the the matrix of what the data looks
like and presented in a four in the
format and and user interface that the
consumer is comfortable with and that's
what they work in for instance we have
integrations to you know somebody might
the bill of material for instance for
one organization is different than
another one right we have we have a deep
integration person to excel so we can
expose our bill of material on the
database through an interface or through
the cad integrations right directly to
excel and allow people to work in excel
like they're used to yet it's it's fully
integrated through the whole design
process on the other end we've got deep
integrations to cad that the bill
material is built through the CAD
integrations and all the way up and down
that and and being able to to allow the
system to be used in the agile fashion
non-disruptive allows us to be able to
integrate all these different players
very rapidly and on board so part of the
problem here is that there's resources
there's not enough engineering resources
in the world right so people are trying
to find resources and technologies and
be able to integrate that to help them
get the product to market and in doing
that they're looking around
finding resources but the problem is how
quickly can you onboard them and have
them be productive in helping you create
your product and that's our vision that
wits streamlet streamlined way of doing
that and being able to integrate this
network of people resources
manufacturing service down the supply
chain as quickly as possible and the
only way to do that is to be non and
disruptive and to be agile and then the
examples of of the application of
obtains cloud PLM is a company like
Apple as an example there are there are
other industry examples that you can
share with us that can illustrate out
the lowest parts of the of the what was
it called the high in the low the up out
of the start and the start of the end
eat the OEM the original equipment
manufacturers down to the base single
component om from the from the finals
and then the the basis to the ones that
are that are doing the components
interesting so then give us more of
these industry examples of up chain in
different industry so we've we've got
the the Apple of print electronic side
you've got the automotive side as well
where you've got a very mature supply
chain however the engineering aspects
are getting more and more pushed down so
you've got companies that are going in
there well we've got companies like
magnet for instance that do a whole
subset of systems they actually do even
the manufacturing is out sourced by the
OEMs to them so they integrate very
heavily they've got a very deep supply
chain that's providing them value and
products and engineering resources and
manufacturing resources we've got
companies in the food industry for
instance which you might not think is
really PLM related but we've got
companies in there that want to
understand the bill of material for them
a bill materials a recipe mm-hmm the
recipe is different for different
regions in Canada for instance there's
certain rules and laws and about a salt
content there's also all sorts of
different aspects of peanut and and nuts
that you have to manage and so you have
to be able to
understand that whole supply chain and
they're providing bits that could be a
simple assault then you've got issues
who salt we were resolved a problem with
one of our customers beet but being able
to manage that supply chain in
developing the product but also there's
certain regional aspects of doing
products we've got one company in Canada
that's using our product right now and
it's all about packaging and the less
cardboard and plastic they use in their
pocket they actually get incentives back
from the government it's great right and
that being how do you track that you
track that through PLM yeah right so it
goes it's very broad in what's going on
in the world and integrating all this
and moving forward we've got customers
right now that are trying to integrate
and we're working with they've got
traditionally it's been very separate
very different disciplines that have
been pretty well segregated and and they
don't work very well together you've got
mechanical engineering Electrical
Engineering a lot of discussion at Co
fest here on on analysis CAE and how
that works and and being able to
integrate it right you've got software
that needs to be integrated now so bring
a product to market right now in is
really key to have all these different
different disciplines working together
on the engineering front but also in
manufacturing service financials bring
them all together yes is a key we are
having projects right now we're
integrating and didn't think of this
ever in my history when all my you 25
years in the industry but linking
mechanical electrical software and
architecture together architects right
you've got you've got different
companies that are building you know not
to get into details which I can't get
into building buildings or architectural
things that have mechanical things that
go inside and the mechanical bit has
changed and it's impacted the building
that the building main structure has to
be moved and they poured footings are
right already and they don't know what
to do now
and the cost of that and delays of that
in the project but if they were
integrated they could actually
understand the links between all these
different disciplines in real time and
it'll manage that how much of a
difference would it make
there's there's you know there's numbers
out there that 80% of of engineering
projects are over budget and
and oh and and they have their there
late right so all this is getting worse
as we go their product recalls on
products are accelerating all this is
because of the complexity of what's
going on and and the more complex it is
the more you need to build a
collaborating real-time throughout that
whole value chain yeah yeah it is the
the numbers of engineering projects that
are now happening around the world from
everything from just software to
buildings and architecture and
manufacture and everything in between is
just crazy the amount that is happening
so like you said to be able to cut down
on some of the resources that we are we
are that the is we're having these oops
moments that are costing lots of money
and so to be able to cut to cut down on
that and to become more effective at
what we're building is very important
where is future PLM going you were
talking about being agile heterogeneity
of data being able to very easily see up
and down from the very customer side all
the way down to the component side being
able to really communicate the trend
that I'm seeing that's going on is you
got you can see it today right you've
got companies that have grown very large
very quickly with very few resources you
look at a companies like Fitbit for
instance right when they went to market
with the Fitbit watches I think they had
40 people on it like you think about the
complexity of that what they've come to
market with and that's the that's
because they the ability to be able to
integrate all these disparate companies
and build a network very rapidly to
build a product to market
I believe I that that is accelerating
we've got the 3d printing so I think
what's going to happen is that you know
people like us working at home will
eventually be able to think of a product
design it through all the systems that
you're seeing here in Co Fez you know
companies that are doing fabulous things
like on shape right online you don't
need to be an expert anymore right to
design a product and then be able to
outsource it and get the resources you
need as a single person not even just a
small company and get your idea maybe
not to market but get an idea out there
and I really think that even get it to
market is is you're you're seeing that
very
complicated products are being able to
brought to market with fewer and fewer
people if you think about it before
getting a Fitbit watch 20 years ago what
kind of organization will be required to
do that and what was required right now
similar to this program that a used to
be a multi-million dollar television
that correct exactly right so the
democratization and the ability to scale
very complicated things and and people
they able to do it as you know in teams
right now we're before his whole
company's now you can do it in as small
teams eventually you can do you'll be
able to do it as an individual and
that's that day is happening it's coming
very quickly right and so just think
about the the impact of that and all the
ideas that people have in the ability
for them now to be able to actually see
their ideas come to fruition that and
the key for that is PLM yeah interesting
so when someone gets these creative
ideas that they can very quickly rapidly
prototype and make sure that the the
idea that they don't have to do maybe
some of the repetitive math and physics
and thinking yeah and they might engage
someone that knows the physics right for
a short period tell about their project
engage with them very rapidly so it
becomes a nucleus of all this it's the
center point for all this and engage
with some find someone engage with them
add them to the project have them add
their expertise to it and and build the
product into a market this is so
interesting John we're really excited to
see what happens with up chain down the
line and with the future of PLM and
everyone thank you very much for coming
on to the show thanks for having me a
great chat lovely I loved what you love
what you're doing it's fabulous
thank you we were greatly appreciative
of that and and the more that we can get
like you were explaining these types of
conversations out there that we can get
more of the of young people figuring out
how to get their ideas out into the
world leveraging software technologies
all right yeah and that's that's my
vision that's what will enable our you
know we spoke about this a little bit
last night at dinner right to the
advancement of who we are and what we're
doing in the world and and with and and
and potentially meet all the vast
challenges that we have on this play
yes yes that's right that's right unlock
that creative potential I love it thank
you everyone for tuning in we really
appreciate you'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below also go
and check out --up chain and John's
links they're all below as well check
out Co fezzes links support the artists
and entrepreneurs that you believe in
our links are below as well and go and
build the future manifest your dreams
into the world thanks for tuning in and
we will see you soon everyone alright
thank you thank you